– Tja, und zum Schluss müssen die Leute
nur noch bestellen.
– Also kurz gesagt: Zuerst entwickelt deine
Firma eine App für unser Angebot.
– Richtig. Und wir werden einen Flyer und
eine Website erstellen.
Aber ... ja, die Gerichte werden von den
Kunden bestimmt über die App bestellt.
– Okay. Die Leute bestellen über die App
und dann wird es
mit Yaras Fahrrädern ausgeliefert.
– Im Prinzip ist das richtig.
– Aber das Besondere ist:
Die Leute können wählen, ob sie eine
fertige Mahlzeit bestellen wollen
oder nur die Zutaten.
– Meinst du wirklich, dass das Angebot
angenommen wird?
– Na klar.
Außerdem wird in der App gezeigt, welche
Gerichte es für Vegetarier oder Veganer gibt
oder Menschen mit Laktoseintoleranz.
Darauf wird dann auch geachtet.
– Das hab ich so wirklich noch nicht gesehen.
– Ja, das ist super.
Aber ... wozu brauchen wir einen Investor?
Ich mein, so teuer ist
das Ganze doch gar nicht.
– Wenn das Konzept funktioniert, könnten
andere Restaurants einsteigen.
So könnten wir in der ganzen Stadt
und irgendwann vielleicht
im ganzen Land liefern.
– Ich weiß nicht …
– Tarek, komm schon.
Das ist unsere Chance!
– Dieser Investor, wann können
wir den treffen?
– Wenn du willst und Zeit hast, sofort.